après un passage obligatoire pour les
mains les visiteurs du jour doivent se
rendre à l'accueil pour vérifier leur
inscription
seuls les groupes de six personnes
maximum sont autorisés et doivent
s'inscrire en amont afin de réserver un
créneau horaire et depuis l'annnonce de
l'ouverture de ce musée
le téléphone sonne régulièrement en
début d'après midi on a eu plus d'appels
pour aujourd'hui pour demain et voir
pour la semaine prochaine aussi une
unique partie du lieu est proposée à la
visite
la galerie contemporaine car jugée
suffisamment grande pour permettre le
respect des règles sanitaires selon
l'établissement
de leur côté les visiteurs retrouvent le
plaisir de déambuler d'une oeuvre à une
autre retrouvez retrouver des habitudes
qu'ils étaient perdus qui était oublié
qu'il manquait c'est intéressant aussi
dans le sens où le maire il a décidé
quand même une certaine organisation
pour permettre aux gens de venir mais
tout en respectant les règles sanitaires
le maire qui est à l'origine de cette
action est également le président du
musée pour lui il n'est pas normal que
les lieux culturels restent fermés il a
donc essayé de trouver une faille afin
de contourner cette décision le décret
prévoit de fermer les musées ils ne
prévoient pas de fermer les galeries
première premier point puisque les
galeries d'art sont autorisés
deuxièmement comme on me contestait
cette notion j'en ai fait un lieu privé
ça n'est donc pas le musée qui est
ouvert c'est une salle privée
contactée par téléphone la préfecture de
l'indre a indiqué avoir présenté une
demande de suspension de cette décision
auprès du tribunal administratif de
limoges
la date d'audience n'est pas encore
connue en attendant le musée est ouvert
et ses oeuvres restent visibles jusqu'à
nouvel ordre